on Serbia's version of Big Brother a
daily diet of fights and punch-ups helps
make this one of the country's top-rated
TV shows
when debate doesn't work fists can fly
there is a huge problem in Serbia with
violence being accepted as a matter
Banya is a lawyer for a group that helps
women affected by violence 41 percent of
serbs think domestic abuse is the top
issue women face here the highest rate
in Europe this is something that even
not even children in the kierden garden
are being taught to resolve disputes in
an elder alternative measures and so the
the TV and what is happening in our
National Assembly and the message is you
know whoever uses violence he will be
the one who who is winning the dispute
and will be you know the winner and
that's the wrong message being sent all
over again
in early May eight children and a guard
were shot dead at a school in Belgrade
the suspect is 13 years old prosecutors
allege the boy's father took him to
target practice and didn't properly
secure weapons the next day a 20 year
old man killed eight people in a village
outside the capital
since then thousands of people have
protested weekly in Belgrade accusing
the government of encouraging a culture
of violence in society
the problem of violence in Serbia is
bigger than than weapons that are in
possession of citizens that's why the
citizens ask for other regulations maybe
tightening gun control legislation and
fundamental and reforms in education and
other seriously Serbia's President
Alexander vucic has pledged to
practically disarm his country more than
40 000 weapons and two million rounds of
ammunition have so far been handed in
during a government amnesty but there
are more than 750
000 registered weapons here and
officials estimate perhaps a similar
number unlicensed it could take years
for the state to disarm its citizens and
they'd have to be willing Partners in
the efforts
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Belgrade